so Clara and I watched conjuring tulasi
conjuring wondering you know what you
don't need to see why I've watched well
I just haven't seen it should I yeah
tonight no yeah you scare easy
I mean I like scary movies yeah you know
it wasn't it wasn't masterfully crafted
like I like like the movie the witch was
so beautiful everything about it the
music art house film yeah but but this
movie was just to me straight-up scary
really yeah I mean I I love yo we were
screaming I got elbowed in the ribs by
him yes I scream loud huh like really
loud really yeah I screech like I you
know what we got yelled at by the people
in Jessica kicked we got the girl a
break or elk rut holding each other and
then the guy like turned around he's a
came out kick her chair Bobby Lee stop
but it was pretty [ __ ] scary you know
and in the English are scary mm-hmm
there's something about English kids
with a crooked teeth yeah yeah and
they're bad feet blanchett feet she's
different
I thought that was something that was no
young nice feet Kate Hudson's English
she's Australian right oh no she's
British I think
no look it up I don't know I don't care
you don't here I would like a wave
riddle I can't wait for Kate much at the
list of this no but the the movies based
on true events
oh it is though should that even make
some Australian but yeah it's it's um
it's a real case called a haunting at
Enfield that's what it's called an
England okay and if you look at YouTube
the BBC they have the real recording
yeah they do yeah real images the real
images and stuff and it was a real thing
and it's like no thank you
is the first one good Annabelle right
is the Dutch movie good first ones good
good and I can find out Netflix where
can i watch I will give you money iTunes
on during the first conjuring it wasn't
need your conjuring money oh yeah we're
gonna watch conjuring didn't we he has a
girlfriend so like give him another
couple now happy you can't worry that if
you don't take that money you can't
afford this if you don't take this money
right now to watch the contract not
listen to me right now Louis listen to
me right now there you don't [ __ ]
take this money for the conjuring you
and I are done that's true [ __ ] money
this is how much we pay our guests for
podcasts appearances such as taking a
new magic tray
[Music]